on the Avatar sequels we rely on them to
not do stunts that stand out as
spectacular we ask them to do stunts
that play as part of our story's
narrative
for the James Cameron film The Action
fuels the story while the story also
feels the action and it makes it so
Dynamic and makes it so engaging that it
makes you want to know what happens next
Jim of course doesn't like things to
just be animated you're going to do them
for real the only thing we're not real
is us being blue
I've got a dry team and I've got a wet
team some of the things that we're doing
are going to be 30 feet in the air and
we'll let the actors Do It full on and
we'll catch their movement they're
acting and everything and then we'll
build it up and we'll let those seasoned
professionals those parkour
professionals do that same motion who do
all the slinging climbing falling
grappling and all the action through the
air
those guys never slip so from fighting
falling parkouring we have the best in
the world for each individual piece